I want you to got gathering information
from outside yourself.
Oh,
start gathering it from the answer.
He made a mistake
and he paid for his mistake with a lot
of pain,
a lot of tears,
and there came to a point where he knew
he should have gotten a divorce,
but he was stuck.
He was stuck in something called
revenge.
He said,
she's made me so miserable,
I'm going to pay him back.
He was stuck and he stayed in there
longer than he should have because it
began to attack him.
It began to affect them psychologically.
He took that same attitude to other
relationships looking for something to
go wrong.
He was burned so badly.
He did not want to risk pain again.
He was going in relationships trying to
avoid pain.
When it became two calls,
he would do something to make sure the
relationship did not work.
He would always try and find something
wrong.
The person,
because they're not perfect people,
so if you look forward,
you can find it.
He was stuck
in revenge.
Is he difficult?
Sure isn't.
Anything that's worthy of character
building.
Sometimes I have to forgive the same
people over and over and over again.
However,
forgiveness is a practice worth
cultivating,
worth experiencing.
When you forgive somebody for something
that you perceived that they've done
wrong to you,
you are releasing that animosity,
that energy that ill will,
that you're harboring inside and it's a
lot more difficult than just merely
saying,
I'm sorry.
I once heard somebody say that,
I never met a critic that's doing better
than me.
I never met a hater that's doing better
than me in that.
That's the truth.
I love my haters.
I love my critics.
You know,
it would be amazing.
It'd be amazing if motivation on the
Cape and positive places engine.
A lot of people say that.
A lot of people speak on that.
I don't,
I don't think that's true and I strongly
disagree.
Truth is,
I don't think people understood what it
was I was doing at Schafer.
I wasn't there to conduct when you
fucking moron can wave his arms and keep
people in tempo.
I was there to push people beyond what's
expected.
I believe that is
an absolute necessity.
I think you become more motivated when
you're able to transform it and it into
a positive and sometimes our best
motivation.
Sometimes I'm my most motivated by my
critics,
but people who are negative,
but people told me,
who told me I'm too young for people who
told me I can't do what I'm not cut out
for it.
That drives me.
Find out the reasons that will make you
stronger.
Make you walk by faith and not by sight,
and will make you pursue your dream when
everybody is against you or don't
believe in your number and let me tell
you something that's a lonely feeling,
lonely feeling,
particularly people that you're doing it
for or people that stand to benefit the
most.
Or people who should be the number one
members in the encouragement club,
but they end up saying you can't do it,
and they become members of the
discouragement.
Oh,
it hurts very badly.
I know what that's like.
Have people that you love close to that
look at you with that look and say,
why don't you try something else?
Why don't you give up?
But this is my life.
I have got to do this.
Everyone tells you what to do,
what's good for you.
They don't want you to find you all the
answers.
They want you to believe that.